so I'm going to tell you bigger story
right I'm about to show you a result and
we're gonna prove it and then we're
gonna use it but I want to give you the
context for the result and why I'm
showing to make it a special female okay
so this is a book this is a really
important historical book which I am so
thankful that you and I don't need to
know about I'm gonna talk about it's an
interesting piece of trivia it's called
a book of long tables so what this is is
before the days of scientific
calculators where you can just punch it
log of why they ever on earth I want and
get a decimal value too who knows not
many different places okay scientific
calculators quite accessible so these
books are essentially right log of base
10 base to whatever you want of all of
the different numbers right so if you
wanted to find the log of a bases or
whatever you take okay well I'll make I
do it that is that some picture 74 and
you go there and then you'd find it and
you get a decimal value so I get four
decimal places from memory okay so this
is before scientific calculators so
we're thinking like 1968 HSC you carry
one of these into the exam room okay
this is you know you're doing about a
reference sheet this was their reference
sheet the whole book always had what
happened then was scientific calculators
became a theme they became affordable
they became small enough to use they
didn't take up entire rooms etc so they
became part of the policy for the age of
see yeah all right now you can't bring
any material with you into anything so
yeah in New South Wales anyway now when
scientific calculators came in they're
like cool we don't need to use these
anymore but math teachers said hey
actually there's something in that book
that we want there's a single page which
I'm about to show you so if we go here
let's go to last year because you're the
first year that has changed this if we
go to mathematics and there we go
yeah yeah so this was the literally the
last page of the book of what image
right because it's kind of useful
mathematical stuff and teacher said hey
hey wait wait don't just drag that log
table stock calculators at least the
calculators back then they can integrate
and this calculus stuff is useful to us
we want this page so they're literally
got the book of hot tails and they
photocopied that page and this is it
this is it now what your lettuces you've
got all of these familiar integrals and
then nestled down the bottom here
underneath the inverse trig integrals
are these two guys and you're like water
those they're not in the syllabus what
they will on the page that this is
photocopied so they just sort of came
along for the ride and when it got
retyped one day last decade or so it got
retyped with these because it's like
what that was the table of standard age
of course okay these are not in this
syllabus there's a reason why they're
quite hard to develop I'm going to show
you them today okay so these two results
they're kind of on they kind of married
together you can see how they kind of
connect when you've got a sum of squares
on the bottom here right you're going to
tan inverse when you've got the square
root of the difference of squares and
you're getting sine inverse but if you
combine them or you reverse these around
so for example here's kind of like a
it's not quite signed in this it's not
quite telling us there's the square root
that you were expecting but you don't
get the subtraction right so you've got
a sum instead or here if all you do is
switch them around
we know switching things around like
that can make a big difference it's the
difference between an ellipse and a
hyperbola yeah so you actually get
something completely different here
versus here even though all you've done
is turn the sign around okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to get
these two results they're really kind of
one result in two cases so I'm not going
to prove it twice women should prove it
once sorry rather I'm just gonna prove
one of them so this is the result we're
gonna look at it see it's questions four
and five in exercise five point three so
the first thing I want you to do is to
month
write it down
say what we're gonna do so we'll say
we're gonna do a witch what did I have
for it because I have sorry let me tell
you which one we're going to do we're
gonna do the positive case yeah let's do
the party okay okay so can you write
this down for me this is what we
required to prove yeah there's that
and because we're writing it without the
context of the standard issue rules in
Russia
can you make sure you add the direction
okay that's what you're right so we're
gonna prove this result okay now what
you look at this on the face of it the
idea is you start from here and you look
at that you do some stuff with it and
he's wait you wind up okay but it's like
what on earth could you do with this to
end up here like that's it that's a mess
right so what would you do what kind of
strategies do we have to prove this
would easy tactic and detective the
textbook takes is to say well why don't
you start with this and go in reverse
right so he's armed he's method one and
to its credit the textbook has done this
because this is by far the most
efficient method right so what I'm gonna
ask you to do and I'll give you a bit of
a hint style because it's it's still not
that entirely straightforward I want you
to take the derivative of this I'm gonna
that's x squared I'm going to leave off
there constant because as you know in
this context it's it's we should have to
differentiate this and we should end up
here right that's why I'm expecting okay
so would you go ahead give that a shot
and then we'll come together in a couple
minutes you can see I'm just going to
upside it off already I'm gonna fill in
the gaps what's my first line what is my
first time
that's F dash on F yes so you can see
I've written it in this sport because
there's my curly gnarly part of this one
okay that's a bit of a mess but it's X
square plus a square to the power half
just so I'll just do my chain rule on it
there's the inside there's the outside
off I go okay now this point what's the
obvious thing to do to try and simplify
this especially because you know where
you're headed
okay so I see I see this guy this guy
right
and it's like it shouldn't be here so
the easiest ratas you need to see is
well if I multiply by this over itself
right this is going to resolve a lot of
things for me okay
now usually we would say oh cool I've
got that thing it's going to become x
squared plus a squared without any
square roots and that kind of thing but
actually in this case I want there to be
that square root on the denominator I
want that to stay put so I'm actually
not going to touch this part of the
denominator this part of the fraction up
I'm just going to use this and you can
see what unfolds right when I multiply
through the numerator you're gonna get x
squared plus a squared can I multiply by
1 plus X aha you see it right that's why
you don't touch the denominator you just
leave it what it was before and what
you're left with off the right-hand
fraction is 1 on this is what I was
after
yeah so cancel cancel there it is right
so what's left for me to finish is that
I've got the derivative over here so
what am I gonna do to this line in order
to get my result what's there right I
just need to integrate both sides with
respect to X so this besides of course
back there this is going to be the right
hand side over here so when you
integrate this with respect to X it just
hands you back that so this is just
going to be that plus my constant and
this of course is the integral with
respect X I'm just stating